The clock strikes noon and it's time for lunch.
Japan's elementary schools have their own unique style of providing school meals.
Everyone takes turns helping to prepare and serve lunch.
Today, these children are responsible...
...for bringing the food and tableware from kitchen to classroom.
The day's servers wear special white hats and hygienic garments.
School meals are seen as a teaching opportunity.
Children learn to serve food, table manners...
...and how to eat different kinds of meals.
Meals are eaten in the classroom with desks pushed together,...
...so groups of four or five pupils can dine together.
The pupils on duty that day read out the menu.
Before starting to eat, everyone says "Itadakimasu!",...
...an expression of thanks for the food and the people who made it.
Homeroom teachers sit with their pupils and eat the same meals.
The menu changes daily,...
...but usually contains a main dish, vegetables, a side dish, soup and milk.